at the big Thanksgiving show and I would
stone people that's not too long ago my
favorite part of the whole night is that
chip gave me his own intro to read oh I
just deadpanned it the crowd which was
kind of it was like a throwback to the
old tenacious d yeah videos but just to
see it dawning on people that chip was
coming up [ __ ] great that was very
fun and then just to do the joke I
watched at the moment where and chip
dropped the mic it just happened what do
you want while we're talking about it
before you move on you want you want to
hear these big a and so I would like to
guess which ones do you have Travis I
have I have yours well Jim's I didn't
know big a Turkish sort of shot I mean
you got Thanksgiving show right yeah
just just you could probably just do it
as bringing him up and I have your intro
as well yeah and just let it roll if you
want to stop this might even help you
with your stand-up he works with cards
Jimmy if you just Wow you know small
cards you'd be able to keep the act
together you're not sitting there
memorizing I do have a punch line setups
like small car you get a little index
card little index card you're going
through it
sure hell yeah I mean there's no teacher
here we're not taking tests because a
lot of times Jimmy you're great but you
you forgot I forget my place yeah I rely
on key words where he does he allows the
energy of the moment to carry him
through right and then there's no need
to worry about what you're gonna say
nice right there on the car there
there's another card yeah for the next
joke I these are all cut up a separate
clips this is that anyway you want to do
it big a at Thanksgiving show there's
still somebody out there ladies
gentlemen ready to walk that line it's
big a the insult comic residue or it
really sounds like a soccer game now it
really does I swear to god it sounds
like the advice I give myself in the
mirror every morning
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh you want to play I mean you know even
when it's even when it's headed in your
direction sometimes you just gotta tip
the hat to the absolutely you can't be
the hypersensitive [ __ ] that gets
offended while everybody else is
laughing all right so we started with
joke to feel like there's some
misdirected energy in the room that was
the shot at me the shot are you okay
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the pacing is really yeah that's awesome
the thing that's great about big a is
you're not sure if he's gonna use the
clinical term or if it's gonna be a slur
you can't say that sexual fearless -
yeah we've got the crowd on his side
yeah yeah yeah and the cards help the
cards it's all about the cars we call
them confidence cards I understand yeah
they're very very important he really
did kill Bay well yes oh there's another
one okay I'd love to hear it I see
please George's better
I love that he won't ET we wouldn't drop
it like four times in a row I see yes
see so in size here yeah just genius I
just love it did they I don't know
whether you guys wanna keep doing this
sure but this is him at the stand did
you get that check with Chris Stanley he
was supposed to send it to you yeah was
that because I'd be happy here more big
a insult stuff yeah is a true delight
yeah he's just so insulting yeah and it
hurts but it also helps I was thinking
this I think I'd feel bad if he didn't
pick on me and he did everybody else
right you left out yes you know you're
right so Lily you want to know that
someone likes you
right and anyone who understands humor
knows that being made fun of is good yes
right yes yes that's how I feel
although unless you're unless you're a
q-tip and you're mad at the Grammy
Awards have you been did you you I know
Jesse got eight nominations I didn't
give a turkey whoa Jim I know we're
trying to be controversial and I don't
get a turkey but I mean this is too much
they announced the who gives a turkey
that's her smokey the Bennett when
snowman and ban hold on for they did
they denounced they announced the Grammy
nominations yeah and a couple people are
upset about it
ed Sheeran fans got upset I know blame
them because this was the this was the
first year in 19 years that no no white
man has been nominated for album of the
year really which is probably just a
coincidence they probably didn't do that
politically free I don't know Sam you're
very you got believing oh maybe yes
little yeah yeah so but they made ed
Sheeran fans upset sure because they
felt like his album should have been
nominated being victimized by the times
yeah maybe his fans give a turkey Turkey
they do and then q-tip was super pissed
he put out a video because good you know
q-tips in A Tribe Called Quest and fight
dog five dog died this year right yes
terrible and so this is the last trife
dog quest sure album he performed
last year at the Grammys and it really
seems like it was one of those things
where there was an understanding like
yeah I don't want to perform but I will
perform if to get to Grammy and then
they didn't nominate him for it he just
he's not even asked for album of the
year he's asking for Best Rap Album yeah
and they didn't know I even nominated
for that they didn't nominate a good
it's not great jay-z to young man's game
I'm fifth forty or fifty yeah what
happens you get better with age don't
know you don't you don't get better with
age you don't know you're not doing the
best work of your life and some things I
am radio no [ __ ] Jimmy you're 50 years
young I had a boy Ron that's what I say
to myself
absolutely I was delivering a chin-up
bar jay-z got nominated for album of the
year and rap out he's saying it wasn't
good enough though maybe the Amish
wasn't good enough Troy didn't like it
I love old Tribe Called Quest's they're
one of the greatest of all times and
this album is pretty weak I I will agree
with you because I saw them or that's a
no and I thought oh this is beneath them
oh yeah the sound of New York in the 90s
yeah I mean that was his they were the
so is that big song I know I remember
they let everybody know that we could
kick it yes yes yeah yeah
yeah we can yes it how I feel why how
did it go yes it was Obama that was in
great years all I'm thinking of in my
can okay can I kick it yes you can can
I'm thinking so yeah this absolutely was
the sound of 90s New York hip hop and
it's real I mean it's still my friend
useless
taggi trains we just because that right
because you get the tags on your high
that's so cool
my tag was always ron was here oh man
get well known for it wow yeah that's
right hey you ron was here yep yeah this
was this was sounds a little bit like
rock him when he raps in that cadence
like that black oh yeah yeah this has a
rockin voice yeah I mean yeah what was
the big song by then this was not the
bigger song this is what this was part
one of their biggest there was there was
one that was bigger I can't know that
Bonita Applebaum was some [ __ ] [ __ ]
was that them yeah but neither Apple boy
yeah I remember those oh yeah that was
the ie I didn't get zip into the mid it
does cut yeah this is huge
[Music]
there is something about complaining
about not getting nominated for a Grammy
on social media that makes me think that
you probably shouldn't have been
nominated for a Grammy like when you
post a video like hey where's my award
it's almost like yeah you probably
wasn't free it's not relevant in today's
hip-hop I'm sorry they deserve their
place in hip-hop history but not I will
say I you know at least be honest about
the fact that the awards means something
to people right like if you say like
here maybe we really wanted that and we
feel like your Grammy does mean
something you know you don't want to say
that these awards mean nothing and then
when you're not offered one be angry
about it just admit that it means
something and then be angry about it but
means album sells well dude are you up
for a Grammy for Best Comedy I'm I am
I'm not even I wouldn't even be
nominated if there was a category for
best comedy specials with De Niro in the
opening I wouldn't be nominated well you
didn't put your your your special ad as
an audio right you didn't put out a CD
did you I don't know
so then yeah I mean that's the only
reason you were nominated didn't put out
at audio I don't know I don't think
Jerry did either did he would that
[ __ ] was he nominated yes that's
great the Netflix thing yeah that's good
40 year old jokes jokes I wrote in
middle school which was great it was a
good special yeah his principal was fat
that's really cool I'm glad the Grammys
were just jumped in on that that's good
stuff boy it's not it's not it's it's on
merit it's not a name oh they're not
just trying to get Jerry Seinfeld the
show up to their say oh they're not oh
no no no okay oh they think it's a
grammy important performance you take
stuff from 1978
good stuff expression down yeah
absolutely
terrific stuff that's freshen travis has
what we were looking for with a game
before oh yeah yes he was roast master
of the year what yeah if I'm Jeff Ross
at the moment yeah I'm sweating harder
than Matt Lauer again good best part of
that was watching you wily coyote off
the cliff with a reference
Jesus Christ like Matt Lauer on crack
ladies and gentlemen try the veal even
try the veal is no good it is that right
now because no one shoves veal in a
comedy club [ __ ] [ __ ]
hope you get shot in the throat likes
alot so I have to I one of Anthony and
one of you said Dave yeah ok so enough
pepper why is that big I know we don't
people did you do shows with I did Dave
fan uh obviously did own a did the after
show there's a pre-show this is starting
to feel like we're not gonna see Norton
again yeah did the solo show well his
people actually disappear and that's
true with the entire staff they're gone
they're gone
what happened to thin he wet yeah he
quit and works in video games
he quit but then he got me he was so
pissed man he he quit and then after he
quit yeah I think he still wanted to do
thin it do I definitely don't wanna do
thin and see him but like he wasn't
around and Dave was like hey we should
do a show and I was like yeah let's
definitely do a show and like I started
having a good time doing that and then
wanted to come back every like six
months and do a thin and Sam show he's
like what the [ __ ] man I thought this
was the future and I was like what I
thought this was a hobby yeah he um yeah
it's funny I see him once every year or
so once or two years but I remember
trying to talk him out of quitting it
was on like Westers I don't where we're
talking I'm like dude he's a comic you
can plug but he was married you want to
have kids he's fun to go in that
direction
yeah was a decision was like he got
forced out no absolutely did we all like
them yeah yeah and he still works in
video games doing like
yeah he was actually testing them for
rockstar for a while he was doing the
stop-motion thing so like when there are
commercials or YouTube videos or
whatever with like wow look at this cool
[ __ ] you can do in this game that was
thin playing the game yeah that was his
job for a while well see I asked him
under bring it asteroids back I'd love
to love to get back into did I like the
old console though III need the old
standing up console the old machines
your Kade machine you're not good with
the system's new with the PlayStation
yeah I was good yeah I mean you know
these guys are a lot better but 1981 I
was good yeah I mean I don't know if you
were paper
what was your yeah I saw it is amazing
but four point eight million four point
eight million with my asteroids high
score but again it's people killed it I
I think I went to 3500 once and
asteroids it could be tough yeah little
hyperspace could be tough big risk I
can't even hear these scores because you
know one of the best things that came
out of the show that Dave and I did
together was the relationship that we
formed with Billy Mitchell right a king
yeah the video game so I mean when you
talk high scores were you aware of him
in that time you know I didn't know I
didn't care about that [ __ ] nerd news
sometimes my friends and his wing sauce
there's that place where is it no I'm
sure where that spot yeah you stopped
there before me yeah it's [ __ ] all
the old games yeah where the crowd is
there nobody nobody it's his [ __ ]
dead as disco literally yeah everything
works on tokens you know you got to get
the Funspot tokens yeah their friend who
got married and I realized that fun spot
was ten minutes away so I was like yeah
I'm gonna check this out and you're
right it was just old games no people
wow so how do they stay open or is it
just for nostalgia or is there somebody
there's a meth lab in the basement and
keeps him going
no I don't know anything about I don't
know how they keep I was I thought it
was gonna be like you're like oh I'm
gonna go there and it's gonna be really
cuz young kids will want to play these
old games no why would they ready moms
and it wasn't like it's not like retro
like Barcade in New York is like they
cash in on the retro appeal
yeah old video games but like it was
just old right it was just like an old
arcade it wasn't it didn't feel like oh
my
this is so this is like when I was a kid
even though it actually was that you
know it wasn't it wasn't it didn't still
smell it oh the new one is nicer it
feels kind of Jabbar hate it's nice see
what happened they also by the way this
is how when they try to go back and grab
stuff pornhub opened a pop-up store and
so how you know do you have to do it in
Soho a bunch of [ __ ] rich ladies with
their dogs looking at a naughty lotion
old lotions and potions PE I think show
me a hole in the wall you goose I think
I think all they wanted to do was the
publicity behind corner hop is a massive
they do 50 60,000 hits a week is that
right [ __ ] yeah could actually be a bit
yeah because they're not gonna get the
press if they just open it in like a
seedy area that's true they're not gonna
get the press think they had people like
oh I can't believe that pornhub is
opening in this neighborhood women
screaming at you yeah yeah no they wanna
they want to they want to class up the
brand they really do they want a cleaner
image yeah I just get the just get the
the logo out there that's all I want
do you have a gorilla at your house
uh-huh Bochy I have a shitty shitty
grill that I wouldn't really use I mean
we got to get a real one yeah do you
think I'm thinking that [ __ ] in the
spring first warm day of spring all the
shows come together and go to your place
and we just [ __ ] grow up some steaks
I love that yeah wait now would you want
to see I can't be where I live I can't
have a gas grill right because you know
the cities are [ __ ] right so I'm not
gonna get I had like a little Weber
outdoor no I've never used I think yeah
by the end of the winter I'm gonna get a
grill do you want a gas grill I don't
know you don't I guess no I don't want
gas I want charcoal yeah oh charcoal
probably that's good for you gets in the
lungs of the juice all right before to
fly the lungs right but it's as smaller
they're only so big they're not that big
charcoal grills I have no idea what I
would get I'm not well-versed in I'm
gonna get a gas grill just [ __ ] cook
in your kitchen what's the difference
you think so yes yes you get it you'd
get a you prefer a charcoal girl of
course I get that one 157
I can swing that I think this is just a
smoker oh [ __ ]
smoking Wrangler grill a smoking
Wrangler is like everything I've ever
been called in my life all the shows all
the comics that's so like a lot so far
no I just thing like I like that all the
shows all the comics plus one all their
families yeah it's not a family thing I
don't think a couple kegs let's [ __ ]
do this I don't know we'll probably just
yeah maybe a BYOB situation maybe we can
have a giveaway yes dude I have a
[ __ ] friend who's an angel dust
dealer no I didn't bring him up there we
all smoked angel dust it's not a relapse
if you're doing it for the show right
I've heard good things
yeah no but I don't want to I don't want
to do all that you ever dude no not
still you know I was a kid yeah did you
it's the worst [ __ ] high and we did
it all that make you feel like it made
you feel like you were paralyzed
tripping is the best like you didn't
have your [ __ ] mind was crazy but
then your body wouldn't do [ __ ]
sometimes we would call people
knickknacks cuz they would fall into
this almost like they were just they
couldn't [ __ ] move and they were like
you're the knick-knack get your
grandma's house and we think that was
hilarious
why would you keep doing it just cuz
that's the [ __ ] that you had never turn
down a drug or alcohol until I quit
never never once said no I went back and
tried to figure out hey was there a time
that I went no I can't do that I'm on my
way to school or to a funeral
never turn it down so I was like this
[ __ ] sucks and I would still be doing
how old were you when you started 14 and
then how old were you and you quit I
quit in increments so I can never have
that one line like I was some oh no oh
here's the problem this and then
starting abuse something no wow you
smoke pot or anything are you do nothing
I now yeah nothing I honestly feel like
I would love to smoke pot but I feel
like that would be like you know it
would really feel good after this weed
that's what I honestly think I was right
though yeah it'll be a problem and I
know that sounds [ __ ] but I just can't
I can't do one
yeah and you start to like your you're
feeling good you just smoked weed and
now you now you can kind of give
yourself permission I would say this I
don't even know if I ever thought it and
anytime it felt really good I just felt
different and that's what I was after
just it feels different than I was
feeling at that moment because you
wanted to feel different or because you
liked the idea of like whoa I can
control I could just make myself feel
different don't know right I know that
you're supposed to know those things but
I was just like I just did it I really
wish I could in let you know much lies
it but I can't I just [ __ ] did it all
right it's like I always say sober slow
on booze enjoy the road wow that's
really good now I'm up to one week at a
time I'm not one of these one day so you
wake up in the morning go I know I'm
good for a week I'll have an aspirin but
I chop it all up and snort it right yeah
it's good for us aspirin no go what are
you doing you're going to aspirin I got
you guys I told you I'm good well I
bring cider in a shot glass nice I
gently spin it with ice in it and drink
it slowly
I do miss copying though there was
something about going to get drugs that
was a very exciting field because
there's dangerous I don't know I just
felt like part of the ritual exciting
this is just gonna be great we're
getting it Oh in this coming and with
the guys here we're going to see the guy
right now is it like when you realize
that I think I'm gonna have sex with
this girl later tonight but like like
like that feeling of like oh my god I
know where this is going and it was
gonna happen after this it was like I'm
gonna do coke with this girl later yeah
I was like I'm gonna have sex with this
person right this girl's clique that's
how we're kind of excitement right right
okay thank you know I've never no never
never do any drugs I never never look at
cliff never I'm gonna make a [ __ ]
promise to you my friend okay I'm gonna
dose you
it's gonna happen right now maybe at the
barbecue that really leaves me feeling
paranoid and Volman
what are you know some with acid uh it
might be acid it might be DMT so you
really [ __ ] did the spiritual drug
for you that scene in in in training day
always freaks me out when he's like
that's when he's like yeah just have
some weed and he thinks he's smoking
weed and then Denzel just sighs I know
you'd like to get wet and you're just
like oh my god it's in my system now I
can't undo this dude I've talked to a
lot of people who said that's the real
dead zone I hope so I hope so he's so
[ __ ] cool that means amazing he's the
best I didn't love that movie but I
loved him
what didn't you like the unhappy ending
you know I don't remember the ending it
was it was more Scarface gimme Oscar it
was a good [ __ ] he should have got it
from Malcolm X dude I had [ __ ] movies
on before that he'd even get nominated
okay he's unbelievable in that more yeah
I great Dainius gredin so much tension
in that scene when he realizes that
Denzel drove away and he's stuck in the
house with the Mexican gang and then
they start going like you get your [ __ ]
pushed in and I'm like oh my oh no
they're gonna push did you scream yes at
the television probably more classic
movies than most [ __ ] people he's
been in a lot of great movies he's got a
lot of them yeah thank you try he wants
now many be doing here's what Denzel
does better than anybody in movie
history slap a cup off the table yeah no
one slaps a cup he did it in American
Gangster when he's talking in the thingy
lots of he can slap a cup of coffee like
nobody has ever slapped the kits it's
incredible
lovely Zeus's lands oh yeah that's good
my man yeah he was so good yeah that
might be that or actually my favorite
things he ever did he was so I love
Malcolm X - yeah merican gangster was
good when he had that what's right
you're right can tear running down is
when he's getting whipped
yeah and you just have one [ __ ] tear
he did that next to when he met Elijah
Muhammad
that [ __ ] he's great that how's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] the Demi Moore tear he can
do that like when he was getting whipped
in and the quivering lip it was
incredible you know what somebody else I
think it was somebody who had directed
him said that if he decides to not be
recognized he could just put on a hat
walk through Times Square and he goes
and one second later he'll just look up
to decide to give a look and the [ __ ]
place will mad rock and then he becomes
Denzel can become Denzel that's amazing
yeah and I know a chick who was a model
she was a playmate
[Laughter]
it was cold you taking Dramamine
but she would she would just decide to
like glow just be a mom yeah and people
would come in and take a picture you'd
see if she would come in do the showed
me she look like [ __ ] and then someone
can I get a picture and you just see her
turn beautiful it happens once in a
while you do it like I find myself doing
that times just because all of a sudden
there's a different person that's the
guy from Netflix Jim that's blue steel
it's a great movie to Zoolander it's
underrated did you watch - though - was
really bad - was really really bad which
one Zoolander 2 and see the one - about
one thing you know I just want to plug
that I'm not doing the Patrice benefit
for this mural but yeah I wasn't doing
the mural benefit either boss is gonna
go to it I want to know what the problem
was with it I have always hated the
classiest organization in football the
New York Giants I've always made fun of
Eli Manning but that [ __ ] literally
broke my heart the way they treated that
guy last night was heart-wrenching yes
you know I know he still apparently he
still I didn't know how much time he had
for the record it was two years [ __ ] him
sit down this dude has never been hurt
yeah like Favre played hurt is he good
time is he playing terrible Eli No
protecting it's a ban ization but look
here's where I put Eli Manning in terms
of [ __ ] quarterbacks he beat the
greatest [ __ ] team of my lifetime
twice right that's right yeah Joe
Frazier is one of the greatest of all
time because he beat Ali once Joe
Frazier is in the short list because he
beat Muhammad Ali this [ __ ] Eli
Manning that [ __ ] weird kid that he
is beat the undefeated team yeah he did
he has Brady and the Patriots number
he's the only guy that has their number
is Eli Manning yeah it's amazing that
that's not enough for a lifetime who's
the coach of the Giants it's not it's
not Tom what's his name McAdoo McAdoo
yes gone by the end of the year so why
are they letting him sit Eli I don't
know unless it's comes from above sorry
buddy unless it comes from above him
unless they're worried about him getting
hurt because they want to get rid of him
and they're like [ __ ] just keep him
protected because he still has value
I want they're gonna get rid of him as a
giant and they little last thing we need
is this guy get hurt we could want to
protect him for next season is
organization maybe because this season I
mean they're doing not they're done he's
they'll never play for them again but
this organization owns I was that
[ __ ] kid yes you there are certain
[ __ ] people the way they played that
you want when the Yankees there's
certain people they let stay around and
next to a couple years because you're
[ __ ] owe them right you know yeah I
mean they did they did I mean regardless
of the motive like the method is
terrible it was one method they did they
told him we're gonna start you next for
the record we're gonna give you the
first half we're gonna take you out of
the second because you can't he goes I'm
not gonna take the record by that you
know I mean they need to say this is our
guy until he's not or play out the end
of this because they don't have anyone
to replace him with well they say is it
to protect them though is it because
like we're such garbage this year we
need you for next year Rob's telling me
he'll never play and this is a good
theory is that they want to lose out so
that they can get out on the draft pick
and Eli's the kind of guy who's going to
try to win games that makes sense
so if you put Geno in there you who by
the way is gonna be the first black
quarterback to start
game is that wrong see now I'm even
angry with the Giants that was a streak
they should have kept going I always
liked that about them and he was even
further from the street than I thought
farmers record is 297 he was five and a
half seasons away he liked things I'm
even closer the [ __ ] this scum streak
but it's his thing it's him yeah you owe
him the fact that he was sobbing like
that it was really bad not [ __ ] I
watched it I left as a man I left you
have a lot more edge than the rest of us
do what did you do laughs Wow
okay cry boy cry ironic man laughs honey
hey George sports fans and then big a is
like I'm one will get you read to murrs
[ __ ] Michael Rooker was great in that
yeah
holy [ __ ] was he great was that Michael
Rooker that was Michael Rooker yeah you
know watch a little of it was yesterday
my coworker I just watch Great Santini
for me so and I he's apologized him to
you he's saying he's going to have to
practice to beat you crying sports fans
yeah he's a little baby
yeah it's writing great that's right
while you eat kind while the Roberts eat
cotton candy to Meechum do something
else I remember it's been 20 [ __ ]
years that dumb film hey boy the sound
of those honey jars dropping ah I took
music I'm gonna watch that right now
it's all I want to see I'm the Great
Santini
he was so good when he was running along
the basketball court just [ __ ] young
you take him out that's right he's so
[ __ ] you would take him out and I take
you out yeah I think that's what he said
I'll be the greatest actor of all time
[ __ ] Denzel and his [ __ ] well Duvall
is good he's very varied he can play a
country guy his shitty
tango dancing when someone gives a [ __ ]
about a play an assassin he's got to be
a
go dancer all right we want to halt we
don't have the budget he wants to tango
dance and murder people I know people
that have tango dance with him he'll
just [ __ ] be at local place
absolutely I could down there yeah and
he has a barn that has does he sets up
so tango dancers go there and they're
just like regular [ __ ] people he
doesn't hang out with stars he wants to
tango dance with people all I would do
is tango dance and [ __ ] accidentally
do Godfather quotes I would learn to
tango just to do it with Tom Hagen and
some dances I just stopping off maybe I
could help apostle I could [ __ ] watch
that crazy movie and I think I've ever
seen the ax possible what the part of
the apostle that I loved and I thought
was so amazingly well done is when he is
breaking down when his wife is with the
kid his ex-wife and the new younger
boyfriend and he's trying to just take
them from the little league game oh come
on let's go let's go and he's just
watching this it's lost and he knows
it's lost he picks up a bat and he
[ __ ] hits the other guy with it I
think he killed him right yeah it's an
aluminum bat and yeah hear that guy's
[ __ ] head yeah what did Woody Allen
did I wrote something Woody Allen's the
third book his book whatever the most
recent was he said something about a
clunk off her head that sounded like he
got hit in the head and it sounded like
the thunk of a ball when you hit a
triple it's one of the best references
to a person getting struck in the head
because what a baseball sounds like when
you hit a triple it's a beautiful sound
terrible
yeah it so stopping rebel because I
couldn't because I couldn't think I
couldn't think about what he was
referencing right but this sound in the
Apostle when he's breaking down
he picks up that [ __ ] bat and he
cracks that guy in the head oh she said
he just sees his wife won't come with
him it's like a ting in a thought at the
same time they're leaving with the other
guy and he says come on come on he's
just trying to make it in he's trying to
make it not solid he just can't do it
great his wife is Farrah Fawcett was she
in that one she was Farrah Fawcett was
the wife she was all I did not remember
that
and our for some majors to me yeah
that's right but you know what I'd be
respectful absolutely I apologize
because Lee Majors the stunt man was
[ __ ] amazing actor six million dollar
man yeah I said I like he's also on that
short list of guys who have sung their
own theme song and he when he had his
[ __ ] the show that was on after six
million dollar man I think he was like a
stuntman who [ __ ] went and arrested
criminals or some [ __ ] he sang the song
yeah and it was he's sang the theme song
so it's him it's Will Smith Will Smith
has pulled it off
there was all chip-chip person chip-chip
person yeah yes he does think Jamey
Jasta yeah yes yes all the greats that's
true all the real greats have done that
that's right all the [ __ ] confident
greats Travis is saying we have to break
shortly okay um we do you want to end
the show oh yeah yeah great with the 8
to 11 boys you're gonna watch a little
bit of Eli before we take a break - yeah
okay Eli Manning yeah he's a simple guy
yeah just has a simple questions act
like I'm and dumb quivering lip man up
you know I don't like it but uh whoever
told you that you could work with men
you start knowing you come out of the
game
to keep a streak alive maybe it's not
that's not what it's about
you know you fairy you know it's not a
pre-season game or you're gonna play you
know start to the half it's the next
week a quarter a series that's not I
also don't know why he's like being
interviewed in this moment I know it's
not the best time is it like why they
like everybody reporters and news though
everybody just jumping in front of him
like yeah like it maybe get in front of
a one of those desks where you can kind
of control a little bit maybe have
somebody speak for you cuz he's a
football player it's not part of it yeah
talking a word Smith go in there and
[ __ ] he's not even a Gino Smith come
on
tied in nicely first black quarterback
racist organization as listen to Mike
françaises rant on this yesterday was he
unhappy about it yeah cuz they're not
happy about it
he was sit down Eli he was great I was a
changed huh did he stay awake during his
rant yeah well that's what he does is
he'll go on a rant like this and he'll
go crazy but he'll use all his energy so
for the rest of the five-hour show he's
doze it off yeah we like a little kid
like he has these giant outbursts is
done he's gotta go down for a nap we got
a couple clips of Mike Francis yeah yeah
a side a by the way at the game Sunday
is going to light himself on fire in the
parking lot he said he's gonna light
himself on fire yes is a way because
he's an Eli fan and he's also been I
know you guys haven't seen him well oh
yeah he's doing a lot of Transcendental
Meditation and he feels like if he
lights himself from fire Wow
perhaps the Giants to turn the around on
this I think it could happen I believe
so I think it's a great idea that's
worth doing yeah uh yeah who is clinging
clinging and in fact that John Mara has
not separated himself from this fool is
hard to believe would be okay if we try
to bring Eli back next year first of all
if I'm active I'm gonna be talking about
next year secondly that's the message
that's the message you're going to allow
this coach who is clearly in a desperate
mode right now he's got a game plan
we're seen again
plan all year from this guy since he's
been the head coach the Giants have
never tell us how you really feel right
up on his tonsils oh yeah oh yeah he
gets pissed Oh
kind of sounds like somebody's got a
tape recorder on the radio though I
don't know if I need to hear all those
clips but uh yeah use past your little
rough one
it was furious we were a little rough on
him no no I don't I mean he's doing the
best he can exactly yeah he's in those
funny jeans yeah sure is Dunga Reese
what is gyms problem with my dungarees
that's where he hides the good audio in
his dungarees how about one more now
you're gonna tell me your plan is to go
to chinos but that's the game plan it's
gonna beat the Raiders this week wait
does this to annoy Jim you really know
he does no no Ron that's not true now
where's the audio from is it really it
doesn't matter I'm not even joking
Anthony [ __ ] tape that his car on the
way in of course he did wait but he
didn't Anthony didn't tape but he just
give us a link to it yeah yeah but other
is there other versions of it of course
yeah we got to take a break anyway
yeah so he just we got it yeah we gotta
take a break a business of course I was
even joking no I know I know but I knew
what it was that's why I was like forget
it I didn't know what was coming before
he did the thing but it yeah that's
right this is gonna be night weight
bother me and I don't want to be like
many I don't want to pick on him but I
think an opportunity
to be sitting around you walking around
your house drinking Maalox tonight this
[ __ ] job's killing me yeah like what
yeah oh it's hard to sell real estate